time to up the bet now that you tanked
two games
yeah we've lost two games so far that's
okay though
because we're just here to chill out i'm
not trying
to be sweaty tonight we're just here to
chill
got a nice open sicilian
rohan chaudhary says we're just here to
chill and play chess
yes that is exactly what we are here to
do
this is true
okay we could see the dragon or the
night orf
bishop g5 i love this line in the night
or okay we see knight
bd7 we see the early night bd7
which i play bishop c4 i think queen c7
is a move here i think it's just bishop
b3
pretty sure this is all still theory
goes b5
have i looked at this position before
i feel like i have
i feel like i have it's castle kingside
e1
waiting for him to play e6 or g6
because it plays h6
classic
do i have this move at all
feels like it should work
but it doesn't let's back it up
so you're telling me this isn't the
tennis stream
okay now we might be able to sack
that might be good
but
might not be good
it's a knight d5
okay
yolo
we'll play knight d5 the yolo move
there's like some smith mora gambit
stuff or night or this is also the night
off
well this opening specifically is a
night or but
this is like some smith moore gambit
idea
i think
it probably doesn't work
but we're just trying to confuse our
opponent
and have fun
trying to confuse them
i do have fishers diagonal for my bishop
you are correct about that gap
it's this one in the sicilian night or
that is what he is talking about for
those that don't know
i dare him to take it
take it
take it take it take it take it
take it take a tick tick
boom
we're causing confusion
yes we are they take and we take
they block with the bishop we'll play
knight f5
check
they can also move the king
okay they decide to move the king
now
i think queen e2 is pretty strong
queen e2 g5 there
you can't take this pawn because there's
a mate threat and we're gonna play
knight f5 next and that looks very good
looks very strong
so right away we're threading checkmate
if he plays something random like
bishop takes d5 which is not a good move
anyway because the knight is pinned
then we wouldn't take the bishop but we
would do checkmate
or if he plays something like queen
takes c2
okay then this wouldn't actually be
checkmate so then we would probably take
the queen
but if he plays something like pawn to
h5
then we would definitely play queen to
e8
boom
okay
so we can check
and he can
block
and he can also
take
and if we take
and he can block and then we can take we
win a piece
or you just take here and that looks
pretty good
too
because then we get the e6 square for
our pony so let's do that check
oh no my queen
oh no
okay so they don't take my queen
classic but now we'll go here
takes
we've got knight e6 we can play
gotta be careful not to trap our own
queen
but i think we should be fine
so we've got two pawns back for our
piece
straight away
which is not bad so even if our attack
fizzles out we're not like totally
screwed or anything
we're only we'd only be a little bit
screwed okay
so
i think this is a really good move right
well no because he can just take with
the queen what am i talking about what
am i talking about bros
okay well
we can also do this
that actually looks really good
because then he has to move the knight
if he moves it to e5 then it's checkmate
and
if he moves it to c5
then we can
take and then if he takes with the pawn
then we can play rookie 8
and if he takes with the queen then we
can play rook e8 and that's actually
checkmate
so that looks very good check
he's probably gonna take because he
doesn't want to lose a queen
and now
his knight is pinned to checkmate oh no
if you move your knight
you can defend checkmate
but then i can play this move bam
also got c7 but i don't think it really
does anything
this is a nice game
this is a nice thematic
sacrifice in the night or
this also applies to some
smithmore gambit ideas
i think the game is going to be over
soon
funkymonk50 what's up yo
how'd the harrison vs harrison stream go
looked like a good game when i looked it
was it went pretty well we were we were
actually both like super tired
that stream
so personally i didn't feel like the
games were like super high quality
because i
i just felt
really really tired
during that stream
but it was nice to see my friend
and
play some games
rook e8
and if knight takes b3
check
okay
now
let's not hang a queen
check
okay
i can play this check
that looks pretty good
because they now have to come to c8
because if they come back then
i promote to a knight
that's actually not checkmate i'll
probably
probably have to promote to a queen no
wait no that is checkmate what am i
talking about yeah that promote to a
knight wait no he can come back to b8
what am i talking about okay so i would
promote me
right so he can't come to a7 it comes to
b7 then i play bishop d5 so he has to
come here
but now
i can play this move anyway and it's a
skewer
and that looks pretty good
check
and now if you come here then i'll play
this move
check
and now i'll take your rook
or i could play queen c6
but i think i'll take your rook
takes
okay
let's finish things off check
and
rookie one
let's get all the pieces working
check
and
let's go here
and let's check
and
let's
checkmate
the the little cheeky we gotta let the
bishop help there
we gotta let the bishop help he was a
very very nice bishop
gotta give him credit at the end there
queen b7 that that's like
stealing all the credit the queen gets
all the credit
we gotta we gotta let the bishop help
out there